can you believe it's been 20 years of
kingdom hearts me neither and yet here
we are with developer square enix using
the anniversary to announce that kingdom
hearts 4 is in the works the series has
taken us all over the disney pixar final
fantasy verse over the years but here
are seven worlds that we'd love to visit
that aren't agrabah or olympus coliseum
okay that isn't agrabah
okay this one's kind of cheating because
in the kingdom hearts 4 trailer we see
what looks like endor and maybe just
maybe the foot of an atst
but regardless it's about bloody time
that star wars and kingdom hearts
finally joined forces while we didn't
see any jedi action in kingdom hearts 3
due to contract complications disney has
now owned lucasfilm for a few years so
hopefully we'll get to see those worlds
collide imagine running around endor
with sora donald and goofy dressed as
jedi complete with the soft john
williams score in the background and of
course a keyblade lightsaber to top it
all off whether it's taking out waves of
imperial troops on the ground racing
speeders through the lush forests
hanging out with ewoks or even taking
the battle to space star wars opens up a
lot of options for gameplay just
if we're going to space maybe have
someone else steer the ship i'm not sure
i could do a whole gummy ship segment
while the fate of the galaxy is in my
hands
kingdom hearts has been edging towards
looking a little more
real doesn't seem like the right word to
use but much less cartoony i mean just
take a look at sora in that kingdom
hearts 4 trailer rip to those giant
clown shoes but i digress they've also
experimented with the more real looking
worlds with pirates of the caribbean in
2 and three so it could be time for the
mcu to join forces with kingdom hearts
honestly marvel movies could make up
this entire list but i'm just gonna keep
it short this could be the perfect time
to have sora and the gang team up with
more heroes so there are two worlds i'd
like to pitch new york and space for new
york i think it would have to be new
york from the 2012 movie the avengers it
means that you don't have to worry about
time travel or trying to find a role for
the multitude of superheroes that make
up the mcu it's a relatively
straightforward story a small team and a
big threat to overcome plus the final
battle of new york really just writes
itself as does the emotional moment with
iron man plus i can already see sora
fitting in with that spinning hero shot
that they do it just it just works and
for space i'm thinking of a pure
guardians of the galaxy romp i just
think that team dynamic would really
work with sora donald and goofy come on
like rocket and donald being curmudgeons
together while goofy and groot become
best friends quill lending sora his jet
boot attachment thingies so he can fly
in the air while fighting
make it so
make it so technically cheating because
niceland aka the world where wreck-it
ralph is set has already been in a
kingdom hearts game but it was kingdom
hearts union cross which i don't know
about you i did not play ralph has also
appeared in kingdom hearts 3 as a summon
with his excellent 8-bit blast which was
so fun that he deserves another shot at
the spotlight
in 3d kingdom hearts games so i'm
proposing that the arcade from wreck-it
ralph is a world for kingdom hearts 4
meaning you can visit felix and ralph in
fixit felix jr sergeant calhoun in the
light gun game hero's duty as well as
get behind the wheel in sugar rush with
vanellope von tweets the arcade would
also offer the opportunity for some
pretty fun meta commentary on a game
within a game within a game
how deep does this rabbit hole go
springfield springfield it's a hell of a
town and crucially one that disney owns
now i bet you didn't think i would delve
into fox properties for this video but
here i am pitching springfield from the
simpsons as a world for kingdom hearts
4. not only is the simpsons seasons 2
through 9 at least one of the most
beloved shows of all time but
springfield is an immediately
recognizable setting full of locations
that would be a hell of a lot of fun to
smack some heartless with a big key in
whether it's organization 13 messing
around with the power plant or nobody's
being bothersome at springfield
elementary i would love to visit it in
kingdom hearts the other part of me
absolutely wanted to pitch futurama
especially as it's coming back on hulu
and namurasan i just want you to know
that i am also open to that
i'm not even sure what you would call
this world ocean great barrier reef
sydney either way it's time to bring
back underwater levels baby
okay i know this is an unpopular opinion
but it's just an option just in case
they need an underwater level for
kingdom hearts for and didn't want to do
atlantica again which let's be real
atlantica has been done and it's never
been the most interesting level
i picked finding nemo because i can
already see the gang hunting for nemo as
the core mission to follow coming up
against the sharks and riding crush the
sea turtle across the eac
basically the only reason i really want
this is because the atlantic forms of
donald and goofy are my favorites across
all the games and i just want them back
okay so inside out may have crushed me
emotionally however i think it's such a
cool concept for a movie and one that
would absolutely translate well to the
goofy no pun intended world of kingdom
hearts plus it would give a pretty nice
avenue for that kingdom hearts melodrama
we all know and love
it's already very easy to see how the
character dynamic would work as donald
is pretty much anger incarnate at the
best of times but i think where inside
out world would really shine is through
exploring the concept of memories
throughout kingdom hearts multiple
characters have lost memories of the
events of the games and it would be
really interesting to see them grapple
with how memory is handled in inside out
kingdom hearts to me has always been a
weird marriage between final fantasy and
disney characters and so for that to be
no final fantasy in kingdom hearts 3 was
weird for many people kingdom hearts was
the gateway to getting into final
fantasy so i propose
put it back
square nx has seen a huge success with
final fantasy 14 and there's the
upcoming 16 but why not put the
characters and location of final fantasy
vii remake into kingdom hearts seven
remakes sure borrowed a lot from kingdom
hearts in terms of how the game plays
and we've already met most of the
characters like cloud yuffie aerith and
of course sephiroth in kingdom hearts
already i will say that if sephiroth is
coming back to kingdom hearts he has to
be voiced by lance bass
no
it can't be
can you take the pain
with all this in mind and the fact that
7 remake part 2 is coming out at some
point taking sora and the gang to midgar
seems like an absolute no-brainer and as
a bonus here are some quick fire
slightly more out of the box suggestions
turning red okay so 2002 might not be
the most interesting world to play
around in but i think this is a good
option for a summon it kind of goes
without saying that a giant red panda
might have more oomph on the battlefield
than a sweet 13 year old gal but you
never know with mei so i'd love her as a
summon with two phases also think of the
sweet sweet background music courtesy of
four town would i love a muppet world
absolutely would muppet sora be
exceedingly cute of course do i think it
would happen probably not but i would
settle for some muppet summons miss
peggy screaming hey yeah as she karate
chops heartless animals smacking
heartless across the face with
drumsticks statler and waldorf
commenting on the absurdity this writes
itself i don't know about you but i miss
the musical minigames from atlantica in
kingdom hearts 2 and i think they should
come back so why not a disney channel
world banner montana high school musical
camp rock come on this is what dreams
are made of
okay i need it on record that was purely
a goof and i do not miss those musical
numbers at all swim this way
what was that about
but anyway let me know which worlds
you'd like to visit in kingdom hearts
for and crucially which ones you don't
want to see come up again
let me know in the comments below or
come find me on twitter i'm at lucy
james games for more on kingdom hearts
keep it gamespot
[Music]